foreign
[Music]
yeah it's award season and everybody's
lists are coming out this is our first
our first feature film and our first
kind of awards yeah experience so let's
so let's start from the top then
um you co-directed this with another
director his name is Trevor back for us
who couldn't be here tonight but do you
want to just start by telling us the
story of um how you came to make this
film we like to say it found us
um this story was found pretty much by
accident so Trevor Frost my partner and
co-director he was in the proving Amazon
actually looking to start a new photo
story so his background is predominantly
in still photography he done a lot of
work with Nat Geo and and other
magazines
and as you as it is kind of when you
start off you know you have to get out
you have to go out and get your own work
and come back to the magazines and try
and get a story together so he was down
in the Amazon looking for the world's
largest snake Anaconda looking to do a
story whereas working with scientists
and a team of locals down there
but as luck would have it they weren't
finding many so he was spending a lot
more time than he cared to admit in this
little town right on the edge of the
Amazon where you see actually some of
the film take place in Puerto Maldonado
and he was in this hotel lobby and was
with one of the the conservationists
that he was uh doing the Anaconda
project with and
they saw Harry walk by in the lobby of
the hotel and his friend said you know
you see that that kid over there you'll
never believe his story
and that was that was it we did we
couldn't believe it you know we we
learned it was that night actually that
Trevor got to
sit down with Harry and learn his story
and at that point
you know you guys all know this isn't a
spoiler
um Khan had passed and so he plugged in
an arc a hard drive with the archive of
Khan and all of his time with him
and pulled it up on the computer and it
was remarkable you know it was
remarkable not just the relationship
that he had with the cat and and the
work that him and Samantha were doing
but when they chose to keep the camera
rolling it was something you don't often
see especially in those really hard
vulnerable moments
so we're Harry and Sam filming
themselves for uh like a social media
thing because that at one point he says
thank you to all for all your support
um and I was just wondering why they
were taking all this footage of
themselves before the before you even
came to make the dock yeah I think it
was
a couple things
um you know this was a very new Venture
in in the scientific world this is this
had never been done in this way before
so I think part of it was scientific
documentation and then part of it was
memorabilia you know Harry talks about
how remarkable it was to be walking down
this trail with this wild cat and
you just he just wanted to hold on to
those moments they were really really
special they were doing some fundraising
uh you know that was your only way of
really keeping the project going so
they would do short you know YouTube or
um Facebook fundraisers and that was
part of it
so when when you approached Harry and
Sam to do the doc was there any
convincing that had to be done or were
they or did they
feel totally on board with showing
themselves and their lives in this way
I think what was what was interesting
about you know when Trevor first met
Harry and Samantha and then told them
about me and my work and how we could
all make this together
um I think it it clicked and it was
there didn't take a lot of convincing
because they very quickly related to
each other
and we're able to talk about things in a
deep way that they hadn't been able to
kind of connect with for other people
that wanted to do potentially at peace
with the con footage so they had been
approached by like BBC and Nat Geo to do
like short segments on it and it never
felt right
and when they when they met us and they
knew how much we cared our whole
background is in conservation
storytelling I've been making short
films for about a decade
um about Wildlife you know and and
conservation they
it just clicked and they got it and they
felt like we
you know the footage would be in good
hands but at that point we thought we
were gonna make a short film I have to
tell you I'm so glad that this film
ended up being about ocelots rather than
anacondas
there's not a single anaconda and I'm
really okay with it
they freak me out so bad Anaconda
there's just gigantic yeah like if one
was here it would be the size of this
front row of seats it wouldn't be trying
to eat you though it would be freaked
out trying to like get out of here
that's true we want nothing to do with
me one thing also I don't know if we've
said here yet is that you know you were
going to because you were asking like
did did Harry and Sam say yes right away
to this and I think
with a lot of documentaries including
this one it doesn't start with like
we're gonna make a big feature
documentary that's going to be on Amazon
and millions of people are going to see
it around the world and you're gonna you
know be really vulnerable and like that
isn't how it does start it doesn't start
though
so I think like you know Melissa and
Trevor and Harry and Sam from what you
know it seems like you all set out to
make this really special like personal
tribute to Khan that then you got the
call from Samantha that Keanu had
arrived and there was another cat so
it's like it kept building on on this
kind of core intention and commitment to
telling a story and then the story keeps
happening in real life and to your
credit you just kept following it into
theirs they were they continued to be
opened and courageous to share so much
of themselves as it was unfolding
um and I think that's part of what makes
it remarkable because nobody said all
right enough with this like you were you
it seems like understood through the
process that the cameras were sort of
part of
part of their world at that point
yeah and it was it was very much you
know from the beginning and yes we did
not know we were making a feature film
so we thought we were making a short
film with the con archive we got back to
Virginia where we're based and
um it was about a month later when
Samantha called us on the satellite
phone and said we just rescued a second
cat
and that was Keanu so at that point we
knew we could follow this in real time
you know it was going to be a much
longer Journey
we ended up doing 13 trips you know each
filming almost uh 200 days and and you
know during production so a much longer
investment than we had anticipated so
Mallory got to watch it all you you you
and your co-director and Harry are
credited with cinematography on this so
we know that the three of you were there
when at one point do you bring on your
producing team when does that have is
that after after you do all the shooting
or
we didn't have an ending yet
did you go to the Peruvian Amazon that's
really what I'm asking Alyssa was Alyssa
there and I didn't know it um I did not
go for this project
um and I have been though to the Amazon
like pretty deep in the Amazon one time
and it was marvelous and uh I would
totally go back again in fact I
definitely want to go visit ohanueva and
see what Sam has going because it's
grown so much but um Alyssa and I have
known each other for many years so I'm
not just picking on her okay I know Jen
program my very first film uh unfinished
spaces 10 years ago at the LA Film
Festival of film independent so um I'm
forever and we just did a q a a few
weeks ago for a year in film yes art and
Crimes by crime so some of you probably
saw it at film independent uh our
virtual series too no I I um I got to
make this film from you know from my
house uh as a producer but um I came on
well Mal was already on and uh did you
go down there no I never went down to
Peru but I went to England and Seattle
right
now she was on production for a couple
but the amount of footage that she saw
and logged with the Peruvian you know
Amazon
she's seen more footage on this project
than I've seen so what Mallory is
learning today is If you accompany your
director and producer to a q a panel
you're gonna get pulled into the Q a
that's a job coming here
um yeah I think I mean I think doc
producing is so interesting because you
know we have an awards for Spirit awards
for truth and fiction for an emerging
director but we do not have an emerging
doc producer award and we've been asked
many times like when are we going to do
it and I'm all for it because I think
doc producing is fascinating but doesn't
seem like there's ever very much talk
about it people don't talk about what
doc producers actually do
um so I'm wondering in this you know
some people say that a story you they
can see a story emerging while they're
shooting a dock and some people say they
don't see a story emerging until they
take a look at all of their footage
there's a lot of parallels that that
happen in this you know because Harry
has to let go of of Keanu Sam haslik of
Harry
um
this was that something that you saw
emerging story wise when you were
shooting it or is that something that
really came out when you were watching
on the footage at the end
I think the story was clear as we were
shooting but it but as it goes in docs
you don't know what's going to happen so
you know we didn't know that all of
those things would start unraveling at
the same time that as Harry was letting
go of Keanu Sam was also letting go of
Harry and those Dynamics with his family
as well and you know the kind of
uncertainty of of their you know son and
his relationship with his brother
there's there's all these parallels
happening and I think
when we saw them it was
it was as if it was scripted I mean you
know there were so many moments where I
remember filming and the hair would just
stand up on the back of my neck you know
when Jaden asked about the cuts on his
arm
and you're sitting that in that moment
it's like
wow you know what a what a true
vulnerable kind of moment of connection
um and similarly like with Keanu you
know when he was coming back to the
platform and Harry's
trying to get him to go away you know
those are like
Free Willy moments you know or like Born
Free like uh
it just it felt
it was clear like these are our tentpole
sorry you know story lines but I think
in terms of the edit it was ratcheting
those in and trying to really just
tighten it and tighten it to a point
where those connections were
really clear and you know undeniable
one of the things that I like I came on
went toward the end of production and
with those final shoots I remember you
and Trevor coming back respectively from
England and Ecuador and just really
knowing that you had endings for both
Harry and Sam and that was that was
something that as a producer gave me you
know even more confidence where it's
like okay this has a we know it has a
beginning and we knew that there was so
much that happened that we would get a
strong middle and but not all docs do
you know that it has a strong ending and
this was one where you know Melissa and
Trevor were committed to following it
far enough that you get not just the
kind of ending that you think you're
gonna get with will the cat survive or
not or will the cat be free or not but
also will Harry and will Sam and will
they get what they what they kind of
didn't even know they needed in the
beginning but what they really needed
you know and it was important to us
two that the ending was you know very
true in the emotional sense that we
weren't kind of kiltering it to feel too
positive or like wrapped up in a bow or
like everything was fine you know or
vice versa that you know that there was
in Hope or Beauty at the end of the the
line so
that was also something that happened in
the edit was how do we refine this to a
point where
it it feels as
close to the truth
as possible which was both you know
there is uncertainty but there also is
Beauty and you know and the success of
likely counting being out in the wild
you know though we don't have concrete
evidence there was a lot to be proud of
um but there was still of course so many
things that they both carried and and
are still processing
and life's struggles
so I want to ask because
you know
um traditionally doc filmmakers try to
stay out of being involved in the drama
of whatever they're filming and what
you're filming here is someone who's
suicidal and so we eventually do reach a
point where Sam
caused the hotline and does something
and and says something
were you and your co-director and your
team sort of questioning about if she
didn't do that where you guys gonna have
to do it or we
how does that play out when you're
making a film about this subject
it was a joint decision so
at that time actually when everything
was kind of unraveling and Harry had the
worst you know suicidal crisis
since we met him
I I was actually back home in Virginia
having brain surgery
so I couldn't be on production and I had
to be back and kind of check out I
couldn't look at screens you know I was
completely removed from the film for
about a month
and so Trevor was by himself filming all
of that and it was
it was it was very much uh his decision
with Samantha to step in
and to call the hotline and realizing
that you know if we don't do something
are we enabling this or are we
encouraging
um or what is our role you know there
was a lot of
ethical questions in those moments and
we decided you know in the edit
creatively to remove ourselves from the
story
there's already so many complex you know
story lines happening and characters
but our stories are very much a part of
this film and you know you see Samantha
that kind of Turning Point with her but
that was very much also a turning point
with Trevor
um and then you know kind of rippled
through to me
as well
yeah I was I admired that about this
project like from the first
conversations we had that you Melissa
and her are coming from a place of real
personal connection
um and Trevor's really uh at if you were
here in the introduction he would have
talked about how he struggled with
depression and anxiety for 10 years and
Melissa shared you know you share about
your own childhood trauma not details
but just that you can relate on that
deep level and it seems like that's part
of what forged the trust between Sam and
Harry and the two of you and also the
ability to like know kind of when what
interventions might be you know
supportive and helpful at different
times not that you always knew and it
sounds and and also the leaning on
Experts which we did in the edit too so
even in production but also in the edit
we had advisors mental health advisors
and conservation experts who we showed a
cut to and talked with about how to how
to handle
um you know depiction or discussions of
suicide or of self-harm and so that was
part of our energy process as filmmakers
so how to show this us so as to make it
less triggering for people who might be
more vulnerable the last thing we wanted
this film to do was cause harm right we
wanted it to be honest and raw and real
and not shy away from you know talking
about mental health and talking about
trauma and showing how people are coping
and and how it ripples onto the people
we love
but not triggering someone or having it
cause harm so towards the end of the
film we we get the update that that
Sam's back in Peruvian Amazon running
her non-profit that she started
and that Harry has gone to another
program in another country is that where
the both of them still are now
yeah so the update on Sam she's
currently in Peru she was actually just
in La for a couple screenings with us
but she's now back in Peru
um we like to talk about this film as
very much an origin story of her
organization and the work that she's
doing and it's grown
incredibly you know it's grown
dramatically since since we filmed this
even just in a few years
um she's now got over 20 Wild Cats she's
built out her team they've learned so
much you know you see on camera how much
growth happened and even just with with
Khan and then with Keanu is this Grand
experiment really so they learned a ton
from that process and has now applied
many of the things that they learned
including the mistakes that they made to
the work that they're doing now so
there's a lot more distance between them
and the cats and how
um you know how can they return these
carnivores to the wild in the most
effective way larger enclosures so that
prey species can come underneath the
enclosure so it simulates more like a
wild environment which means that they
don't need as much human stimulation
um
it's hard because you know when they're
babies they still need that really close
connection and they need to be bottle
fed and
but it's that bond is broken a lot
earlier now
um and she just brought on her first
they just rescue their first Jaguar are
you telling me I can't have a baby
Ocelot because I feel like you're just
if you watch this movie and you think
that you should have a pet outside then
we completely missed the Mark
we failed
no it's uh it's learning it's Learning
Journey and Harry Harry is now
um
I guess he's in he was also with us
doing we've been doing screenings
together so it's all a bit of a blur for
me but
yeah he's he's doing well I think he's
he's on much stronger ground now
um he actually just recently got engaged
and started an organization with his
fiancee also doing conservation work to
help um veterans and other people
struggling
did so did Harry ever and to any formal
kind of PTSD therapy or
was this
the whole process of of traveling in in
working and raising and releasing Keanu
what he considers to be his
his version of of therapy
he hasn't done anything that like talk
therapy Professional Therapy medication
but um you know it was the therapeutic
being outside for him being in nature is
really calming and uh I mean being out
there for it should be said for 500 and
some days is Extreme and very few people
in the world have done that
um and because it's really harsh and
that's not the kind of thing that is
necessarily therapeutic as you see in
the film but being you know like the
reptile work he did in Ecuador the kinds
of things he's doing now he feels he
says he feels much more at peace when
he's doing that work when he's
connecting with animals
and then also um through the screening
the film we've done a couple of
screenings with this wonderful
organization that's one of our impact
Partners called Veterans in media and
entertainment because you know Harry
became really good at filming
um and and photography through this
process too and that's also been
something of a calling for him which
we're really excited about and so
veterans are meeting entertainment did
we did a whole screening with like over
100 Veterans here in La I guess it was a
month or two ago and that was really
powerful where Harry's also starting to
connect with other people who who can
really relate on a fundamental level to
what he's gone through and and what he's
facing and some of them who are further
along on the journey so we're hopeful
that that Network and Community will
also be supportive and and help him find
whatever works for him
yeah so what's next for Wildcat and
what's next for the three of you
as well cut out or is it coming out
Wildcat is coming to theaters December
21st uh Prime December 30th and we're up
for a couple Ida Awards that's going to
be this week congratulations thank you
yeah well we're excited for that
um
and we also have an Instagram account
doc film uh Wildcat doc film okay and
we're also all on Instagram
so yeah and you're making the Anaconda
film next we're on the journey actually
our next song is about snakes yes there
is and we are all working on the next
one somehow I felt like it was gonna be
because there's so much so many tiny
little snakes and the subliminal
messaging we're trying to just ease
people into it like snakes are cool just
prepare for them like our all of our
films will have the animal subliminally
placed before that next film happens is
there anyone who likes snakes in the
audience yay there are more of us okay I
had a snake when I was little named
Bungie a boa constrictor I have a
rescued ball python at home all right
and she's the sweetest thing she liked
to cuddle she takes showers with me
freaked out
at the same time I've been watching a
lot of snake content now we're just
going off the rails we're very calming
like a boa constrictor very common
they're so they're wonderful it's like a
back massage you put them on your back
and they see this is how you do it folks
this is how you lay the groundwork for
your next film
but it's also a human story it's not
just it's it's just very much a similar
yeah it's it's it's
we like to call these backdoor
conservation films you might come in for
the cute cats or the you know the
interesting family Dynamics but you
leave maybe with a greater appreciation
for the natural world and our
relationship to it so
well thank you so much for coming
tonight thank you so much for your work
on this amazing film thank you for
having me we wish you the best of luck
at Ida Awards had some fun tonight
and
um
happy holidays tell your friends tell
all your friends we'll be in theaters so
yeah see it again check it out
[Music]